[Applause]
behind me is my new truck or bucky as we
call it in south africa and
does it sound good
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
me
uh
[Music]
[Music]
whew
[Applause]
as i told you before this video was
brought to you by epidemic sound my
go-to sound and music library epidemic
sound makes your job as a freelancer or
creator as smooth as it can be no matter
if you're editing a commercial or
creating an instagram real their sole
purpose is to empower creativity and at
the same time make life a little easier
for you by signing up to epidemic sound
you get access to 35 000 tracks and 90
000 sound effects and a wide variety of
moods and genres with curated playlists
for occasions and themes it's easy to
find what you're looking for and you can
enjoy fresh new music added every week
you can now get personalized
recommendations of tracks based on your
recent downloads or based on what music
you've used on your channel previously
and the more you use the product the
more they know you and what you like
thank you for watching this week seeing
sounds other than that don't forget
you're awesome bruh and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you